k welcome five-minute game against TM da
fresh from yahwah is not from Antarctica
but this makes you look up the flag
because you have no idea what this is
supposed to be at Sun and optical this
is even the country don't think so yeah
okay we've got an open Sicilian here on
a Paulson variation or tomorrow
variation with Bishop to e3 em I try to
build up something like the English
attack with F 3 which is some sharp
option for white of course but also a
bit tricky for a player like me who is
not a long-term one default player yes
ma'am I know this is some this is an
online but how to continue here some may
be playing d5
are you can can you play a three just
going into an endgame but then it's got
d5 at the end it's not it's not very
attractive-looking i can go nighty too
for example to stop protecting this but
then d five maybe can i play at all i
hope on d5 i can play a five Queen takes
d5 Bishop f4 Queen f5 and then g4m this
kind of motifs are sometimes working the
problem is look at the time hey yeah
well in fact my rating is very good at
the moment 2 for 16 in the five-minute
pool usually if i'm not playing without
doing the live comments i managed to get
on this on this level um around 2450
something I can reach 25 but I cannot
keep that rating for very long because
you simply get get GMS all the time and
I mean I have GM level at blitz but it's
it stepid stuff and now even with with
the live comments and and my wacky
openings I got there so it's quite good
okay I'm how to continue now night on b6
yeah I wants to go to sea for which is
quite an annoyance maybe maybe here
if he gives me this double phones now I
don't mind that so much in comparison to
the position before yeah okay
or queen d3m maybe quindi three
so what now Quincy 30 Quincy for Quincy
three is probably better he can take a
tool but I don't know if this is such a
good idea for black okay he simply
doesn't care I thought Quincy five is an
issue it looks at least like some
compensation I don't believe in Queen a
one context p 2 y Meneses ur not on okay
I admit that I don't have a very
concrete threat now maybe f5 f5 Bishop
g5 but he cannot castle and how does he
extract the Queen he can play Queen a
phone but then I think it should be
compensation just just a pawn yeah this
is a this is one way okay
yo should i take it on and if i take out
on d5 if he's got the knight on d5 if i
don't i don't want that probably you
know yeah its opposite colored bishops
so there's always some some compensation
maybe it's not maybe it's not enough
Jim dad was the pride it didn't know
that the opening in such detail so this
costs a lot of time
yeah well I'm upon down but it's not not
easy technically because of the opposite
colored bishops and my bishop is
potentially quite quite good in this
position on before for example
yeah I need to speed up the energy five
is not a very pretty structure but how
does he make progress
it's not easy at all black toe and to
open up the position okay so let's get
rid of the lights so the only thing is
what I'm wondering maybe I can play six
now maybe he thinks that he can play for
win after that refreshing the exchange
but I don't think he can this is some
just better for white my rooks are are
just active but maybe I cannot win as
well this is possible
yeah well the time
well the way he's playing at him he
might lose it anyway I go all the way to
f7
check
check
check
check-check
check
yeah well this wasn't the best game ever
both players blundering like no tomorrow
yeah what can you say around here after
year I mean this is probably just to
draw this position unless he place this
which blunders material and here he had
I think white what must be winning
somehow and clicking to see three of
course yeah just King 33 King feet c3 to
be formed and then I infiltrate without
giving him this counterclaim this must
be the win computer doesn't agree but I
well I don't trust the computer him to
be honest that must be win it's he's got
one porn and very bad bad bishop and I
won't porn because he six is worthless
and then we got them and now I'm
completely winning and here I must I
must improve of course I I didn't see
Bishop b5 coming and
I can in fact I can play on on a three I
can play rook h6 or some other news
because a to I can check with the rook
and be too i can go ping see to its plus
five but ok so I lost back the rook and
then is somehow managed to to blunder
this away this is already winning for
white amazingly because I just in wait
with the King and love some some more
blunders but we only had 10 seconds left
and at the end of summer wonder scramble
yeah I hope you felt entertained at
least thanks for watching